♪♪
-How's everyone doing tonight?
Worried about your family's
well-being
because you love them,
but also, you kinda hate them
because they're all somehow
standing in your way,
no matter what room
you walk into?
That sounds about right.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
President Trump yesterday said
the coronavirus
economic stimulus package
that was passed by the Senate
was tremendous because,
"A lot of this money goes
to jobs, jobs, jobs
and families,
families, families."
I don't know if he was repeating
those words for emphasis
or just having
a stroke, stroke, stroke.
Senator Mitt Romney
announced this week
that he has tested negative
for the coronavirus
and also, charisma.
Following Senator Mitt Romney's
announcement
that he tested negative
for the coronavirus,
President Trump appeared to mock
Romney on Twitter and said,
"This is really great news!
I'm so happy
I can barely speak."
But then, he clarified,
"No seriously.
I can barely speak."
-Known or suspesked
gang members.
Advising law markers.
Will not be tolerighted.
United Schtates.
-After former Vice President
Joe Biden coughed into his hand
during an interview on Tuesday,
CNN anchor Jake Tapper showed
him how to cough into his elbow
before clarifying, "No!
No, your elbow!
What's wrong with you, dude?!"
Former Vice President Joe Biden
appeared on "The View"
on Tuesday to discuss
the coronavirus and said,
"We have to take care
of the cure.
That will make the problem
worse, no matter what."
I think he meant
make the problem better,
unless he meant take care
of the cause,
or maybe he meant to appear
on "Good Morning America."
Sometimes it is, uh,
it's just impossible to tell.
The New York Post
has published a list
of do's and don'ts
for having sex
during the coronavirus pandemic.
For example, don't have sex
with anyone who went outside
to get The New York Post.
Not even funny headlines
about the Mets right now.
Grocery stores, like Kroger,
Albertsons, and Walmart,
have announced
they will begin installing
plexiglass sneeze guards
at checkout aisles
due to the coronavirus,
while Whole Foods announced
it's gonna start
charging a cover.
"Not on the list, bro.
Get your avocado
somewhere else."
A zoo in Missouri has asked
the public to write letters
to its animals while it's closed
for the coronavirus pandemic.
Said Missourians, "Okay.
I'll get right on that,
as soon as I'm done
working full-time
while homeschooling my kids."
Mommy, we're hungry.
What are you doing?
"I'm, uh, writing a letter
to a howler monkey
who can't read.
So be patient."
Elementary school teachers
in Missouri --
big day for Missouri
in the monologue --
recently drove
through neighborhoods,
waving to their students
after classes were canceled
due to the
cornonavirus outbreak.
Or, at least,
that's what they thought,
until they looked closer.
Today was Aerosmith lead singer
Steven Tyler's 72nd birthday.
Said people shopping for a gift,
"What do you get for the man
who wears everything?"
It's nice to have one
that's not about corona.
Yesterday was
National Tolkien Reading Day,
so, if you spent the whole day
reading "Lord of the Rings,"
you're gonna love
[laughing] page 2.
Ian Morgan goin' hard,
going hard after Tolkien.
On his day!, no less.
Tolkien doesn't [bleep]
on you on your birthday, Ian.
Ian can be followed on Twitter.
It's the worst Twitter handle
of anyone on our writing staff.
I think it's @TheCh(r)isperer.
I don't know.
We can lower-third it,
if you wanna unload on him
for his Tolkien nonsense.
@TheCh(r)isp--
I don't know. Alright.
The makers of Peeps
have announced that,
due to the coronavirus pandemic,
they've been forced
to stop production.
"This is gonna be hard,"
said someone
about to eat a Peep.
Ian again, redeeming himself.
Kim Kardashian West
has announced
that her makeup company
has stopped production
due to the coronavirus pandemic.
At least, I think that was her?
And, finally, Netflix
suffered a service outage
throughout parts
of Europe yesterday,
due to increased
Internet traffic
during the coronavirus
quarantines.
And so did Pornhub,
but no one dared
to admit they noticed.
"Oh, did it? Yeah?
And what is that?
And it's for --
It's for computers?
[mumbling]
No, yeah, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't [mumbling]
I don't know."
Well,
that's the end
of tonight's monologue.
I feel like some of 'em
were pretty good.
I feel like
we're all pretty beat up
over the fact that Ian went
after "Lord of the Rings"
so hard.
Or LOTR, as people
will sometimes write it.
Uh, I don't have
much else to say,
other than I think
my sweater did great today
and I don't know.
If you're still watching this,
This is maybe,
now, at this point,
I'm just seein' how long
you'll watch a YouTube video.
I've clearly run
out of material.
Uh, we're gonna be back
on Monday
with another "Closer Look"
and more jokes
and we feel very lucky
that we still get to do this.
Wash your hands. Be safe.
We love you.